[Music]
on the surface the Ganesha temple in
Queens seems like just a place of
worship for Hindus but if you take the
side entrance down the hall with all the
lights follow the signs down the stairs
follow more signs down more stairs
you'll find the temple canteen a
restaurant serving food to rival
anything you would find in India
[Music]
this is dr. uma Mysore car namaste
I'm the president of the Hindu temple
Society of North America in Flushing New
York the temple came into existence in
1977 and as one of the first of its kind
in North America the temple has become a
cultural hub for Hindus throughout the
u.s. this is a place like home people
who come to the temple spend their whole
day here they have their worshipping
services in the morning and then very
often we have cultural programs but also
they come here to eat they come to the
temple to eat yes they do come here to
eat some of them come just only to eat
not even to come inside the temple so in
addition to a place of worship
a community center and a wedding venue
the Ganesha temple serves cuisine
authentic to South India and is open to
the public and the food is pretty
fantastic
just as the New York Times for New York
magazine or Anthony Bourdain it's not
easy to find our Indian food everywhere
around the corners so people come to
find authentic Indian food okay so if
you don't know anything about South
Indian food here are some of the
must-haves
there's vara I always called it as a
salty doughnuts Italy it is nothing but
puffed rice sambar it is made of lentils
very healthy and most notably dosas
there are at least about eight or nine
kinds of dosas it consists of dow and
there is a filling inside we have about
an authentic Indian cooks
in our Hinduism we strongly believe
without the offering of food to the
deities our prayer is incomplete and
that's how it really started but I think
when you go to a canteen or a restaurant
you want to enjoy your food we want to
make sure that whether it is a Hindu or
a non him though you should be able to
enjoy the food who cares really whether
it is an Indian restaurant or a non
Indian restaurant you just want to go
and eat food so the next time you're
hungry in Queens try the temple what if
I told you some of the best Indian food
in LA is next to this busy highway at a
gas station inside a convenience store
this guy certainly likes it let's see
how this plate of Indian burritos ended
up near the Dorito aisle at the Bombay
Frankie company you'll find Hiram and
his staff making Indian food at a gas
station Hiram care to explain okay
the reason why we chose this particular
gas station is because our families
actually in the gas station giving you
our business we had this space for you
for quite a while and we thought well
what a great launchpad traditionally
what you might find it is unhealthy non
fresh fare and when you're coming across
something that's not only fresh but it's
true to the most raw ingredients so when
we start with that completely off the
wall pairing you're gonna be starting
from a really low point so all you can
go is high and higher and we're trying
to just set the bar really high
since they've opened the Bombay Frankie
company has received both critical and
commercial success definitely our most
popular item is the Frankie in Bombay
sometimes it can be a rolled-up
sandwiches sometimes it can be an
enclosed sandwich what we tried to do is
make it ultimately relatable to the LA
market and make it really similar to a
burrito
it's one of the best things you've ever
tried people say never mix business with
friends or family I say don't knock it
until you try it the key members of the
bumpy Frankie company it's my sister
Priyanka our esteemed chef mr. Komal
Jeet Singh and our staff having someone
come in for the first time who's never
tried Indian food and are completely
engulfed by the experience they truly
realized that not only is it an Indian
food coming from a gas station and being
served in the gas station that they
would try it elsewhere
so by preserving traditional ingredients
traditional corporations traditional
recipes were staying true to not only
ourselves but the region of food for
which we serve and we want to make sure
that you're leaving feel like you got
the true experience Mumbai has over 18
million people the city it's
unpredictable
but amidst this chaos there is one thing
that is nearly 100 percent reliable it's
your lunch delivery
[Music]
the double wellas of Mumbai are an
institution a double wala is a guy who
delivers homemade lunches
didn't go under head or my the ball of
business majority out subsume a no but a
parasail say come Halle Bombay me
homogeneous goal and above Ojinaga come
Ali the cycle our trip you do not choose
us a milky approach an example this is
how the system works the double wallah
comes to your home and picks up your
lunch he goes to the train station where
all the other lunches are they are
sorted and then delivered out into the
city to be dropped off at your office
you eat it the double wallet comes picks
it up and brings your lunchbox back home
that's the keyword home
these aren't takeout delivery guys
they're delivering you a meal straight
from your kitchen
this system while seemingly rudimentary
has been recognized as one of the most
efficient logistic systems in the world
double walas have an accuracy of 99.99%
in their deliveries per million
transactions less than four mistakes are
made substantial think in the bigger but
is your quarterback go to make out the
game at level which a clear knowledge at
a which color combination of time
wealthy but lucky for the big caper in
number up in dollar why Hugh say does
the only boy someone I know
[Music]
Criss crossing side-streets on bikes
balancing trays that way almost 150
pounds on their head this group has 5000
men they help define the city was very
super just a little bit yes system auto
because induces a up in nature
for NASA hard work ahead for a new model
of horizontal elegant
I'm living office manager say start with
heavy these guys are out there six days
a week
monsoon or shine life in Mumbai it can
be chaotic the train might be late your
power might go out but damn it your
lunch would be on time this is what it
sounds like when 3500 people are eating
together another 3,500 and another
in total today the Shirdi Sai Baba
temple in Maharashtra India will serve
lunch to at least 40,000 people for free
and this happens every day 365 days a
year
the temple was built in 2008 around a
specific philosophy by spiritual leader
Sai Baba Baba HRT take correct ID before
carnival night a year has passed our
score
my name is Ajay this is the man in
charge
mera naam Sanjay expansion bar hey Mira
my personal I'm a supervisor case it's a
comfortable he supervises the kitchen or
mega kitchen as this is one of the
largest in Asia the day it starts at
6:30 in the morning except may teen solo
artist resubmitting saw felt a solo
concert a possible what I didn't mean
Rashad Elizabeth does valuation wrote I
not Potter's vajay but no time some
people are cooking vegetables some clean
utensils some are responsible for the
bread you get it
[Applause]
everyday the meal is different but the
ratio is always the same believe me if
green sub G array card and Nikki sub G
dal chapati rice it not get this off to
make these plates for forty thousand
people a day it takes a lot of food here
in the numbers 3.3 tons of bread 2 tons
of vegetables nearly one ton of lentils
and half a ton of dessert now to make
all this food the kitchen requires a lot
of power a sub-sahara ischemia number
though publishing dates a lot of it
the roof is covered in solar panels so
it's clear this temples initiatives are
something to be proud of Santa Rosa is
family a possibility
[Music]
Indian weddings are really huge on an
average Indian wedding that is always
100 250 plates of excess foot that's
where we are coming in electing it and
distributed the needy Indians produce
10.8 percent of the world's food but he
have more and more people hungry in
India slipping without food
I am padmanaban gopalan I started non
profit no food waste in 2014 no food
waste is an excess food recovery Network
that collects untouched surplus food
from various events and parties and
delivers to the hunger spots across the
city like orphanages slums old-age homes
dump yachts and government hospitals as
of today we have collected and
distributed about two hundred and
eighty-five thousand plates of food to
the needy people we launched a helpline
number that is explained in across the
marriage also and the hotels when there
is excess food people called to the cell
plate number then we organized pickups
with our vehicles and this food is being
served within four house of collection
no food waste initially started in
Coimbatore and now we are in almost ten
cities it is only because of volunteers
the number of call is very huge right
now we are able to cover only thirty to
thirty five percent of the calls wat be
received to arrange logistics and
infrastructure to recover food from all
this marriage faults becomes a challenge
people are generally aware of food waste
problem in their marriages and events
but they were not aware of what to do
with the successful there is no words to
explain the pain of hunger the success
of no food waste is to see a food waste
free India and a hunger free India when
we collected all this food and delivered
to the slums in different areas people
feel happy about it and seeing smiles on
those people makes us really happy to
continue this job
feed people not landfills
[Music]